[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur figaro live
on est en direct on est dans les studios
du figaro et on attend vos points de vue
en particulier sur l'hospitalisation de
donald trump le donald at il été trop
présomptueux
pensez vous qu'il va s'en sortir
touchons là les limites du populisme
on en débat ce soir avec je suis très
intimidée parce que je deux journalistes
de grand talent qui viennent de publier
deux livres à lire absolument
vous venez de les voir d'abord isabelle
saporta bonsoir isabelle ancien de rtl
est désormais voie incontournable des
grandes gueules sur rmc
surtout surtout auteur voilà on le voit
d'un livre qui est indispensable à lire
rien que pour le talent d'écriture rien
pour ce qu'on y apprend mais rien que
pour le plaisir de lecture également
rendez nous la france sept aux éditions
fayard
il faut également lire le dernier livre
de yvan hors ue folle le réveil des
somnambules chronique d'une colère qui
monte cette audition de l'artilleur
alors on en a déjà parlé de semaine
dernière j'y reviens pas mais je
continue de le recommander
bien entendu sur ce point vous êtes
d'ailleurs tous les deux d'accord vous
en voulez à cette élite technocratique
des racines et condescendante coupable
dumas rasé de la crainte de la crise qui
frappe en particulier les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes
françaises les français les plus
modestes
donc vous serez d'accord vous inquiété
du sort des propriétaires de bars des
salles de sport et autres boutiques
subissant des nouvelles mesures
sanitaires annoncé ce matin à paris je
vous renvoie donc chers internautes au
débrief qu'on a fait de ses mesures en
revanche là où nos invités ne seront pas
d'accord en tout cas c'est le pari que
je fais ce soir c'est sur les dernières
déclarations du pape françois dans une
encyclique qui s'appelle fratelli tout
petit tous frères c'est pas fratelli
d'italia ses déclarations notamment sur
les déclarations sur l'accueil des
migrants le pape et il courageux le pape
est il angélique qu'en pensez-vous vous
pouvez voter sur twitter vous pouvez
voter sur youtube et on en débat en
deuxième partie de cette émission mais
d'abord dit
neuf tweets en deux heures c'est un
produit donald trump depuis son réveil
et l'hospitalisation mal à vous les
voyez c'est tout ce qu'ils ont été donc
produit depuis ce matin enfin depuis ce
matin depuis son réveil donc c'est à
dire en début en début d'après-midi pour
nous l'hospitalisation de donald trump
ne lui portera pas préjudice c'est en
tout cas ce que vous pensez en majorité
c'est ce que vous avez dit dans la
question qui a répondu à une question
qui vous est posée depuis hier sur le
site du figaro je vous propose de voir
d'entendre plus exactement ce qu'on
pense le principal intéressé
[Musique]
alors vous vient de vous poser une
question sur twitter sur youtube pensez
vous que donald trump a été trop
présomptueux avec le co vide 10,9
vous pouvez répondre avant d'en débattre
je voulais vous soumettre c'est
d'ailleurs le sens de la question de
cette partie ce qu'elle écrit à nos
confrères un ancien ainsi à de grandes
plumes du figaro qui est déjà désormais
dit organise dans un autre journal et
qui voit dans cette contamination et
cette hospitalisation
un signe politique trump dit il comme
molson arrow comme johnson a donc le
brésilien britannique a d'abord minorer
le coc vide
ils n'étaient pas favorables à des
mesures strictes et pas de masque pas de
confinement et le voilà comme contaminé
hospitalisés et dit ce sont les limites
du populisme vivant qu'est ce que vous
en pensez de tirer par les cheveux c'est
pas tout était pas être populiste que
d'avoir des doutes malgré tout sur cette
grande panique sanitaires dont on verra
bien la fin si les chiffres
correspondait vraiment à la menace qui
avait été établi il est possible que non
ce qu on se rendra compte peut-être qu'à
la fin de l'année les morts ne sont pas
aussi importants que ceux de l'année
précédente enfin on verra
et donc le plus à faire un procès en
populisme quoi qu'il arrive dès que
trump dit quelque chose ou fait quelque
chose où harry ou qu'il arrive quelque
chose à 30 me paraît être un mauvais
procès moi ce qui m'a le plus choqué
c'est le pardon c'est un mauvais procès
passés comme le roi des populistes ivan
rioufol on peut pas dire le contraire
il est quand même d'ailleurs même assez
fascinant c'est que là on voit bien
qu'il est en train d'endosser un rôle de
survival c'est à dire qu'il a vraiment
ce qui est fascinant avec train parce
que de fait comme tous les populistes il
a quelque chose d'assez fascinant c'est
qu'il a minoré effectivement totalement
le coronavirus on a vu que même jusque
jusqu'au débat avec baden
ils n'étaient pas masqués aucun de ses
proches était masqué il en faisait même
un argument politique total il ya un
cluster à la maison blanche mais c'est
pas grave tout ça est balayée d'un
revers de main et maintenant c'est le
survival du coronavirus effectivement
c'est assez fascinant 7,1 mais fascinant
semblait à avoir avoir à lire le titre
de votre livre que le populisme était
quelque chose que vous auriez pu
comprendre parce que malgré tout vous me
semblez être davantage attachés à ce que
représente aux aux inquiétudes du peuple
et les inquiétudes du peuple n'était pas
de temps sur ce virus sur sur leur
propre ville
habilité plus générale leur
vulnérabilité identitaire c'était ça
dans le fond ce qu'on pouvait reprocher
ce qu'on pouvait ce qui était le combat
de trump donc c'est vrai qu'il a un peu
laissé tomber c'est ce ce grand combat
cette guerre pour reprendre l'expression
du manuel mâcon contre un virus
je pense que en effet il avait plutôt
raison de voir que les les protections
qui était exigée des peuples et
singulièrement aux états unis mais aussi
en france étaient des protections qui
était plus existentielles que de faire
la guerre à un virus mais maintenant je
trouve c'est un mauvais procès encore
une fois de le faire et j'ai été choqué
c'est ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure j'ai été très choqué par la
jubilation de ceux qui détestent tron
qui en y voyant un populiste qui verrait
peut-être une chose infernale qui
souhaitaient quasiment qui visiterait
pas ce qui vient de fêter sa mort qu'il
souhaitait y est j'ai été vraiment mais
absolument et pousse plus ahurissant de
voir ça vous étonne jamais je ne sais
pas que cela m'étonne pas c'est
tellement bas comme comme argumentaire
que de dire que trump rispoli passeuse
dyson à retirer toutes les publicités
négatives qui l'avait fait contre lui
donc le banc weiden a été nickel après
que très bien très bien pour bayonne oui
j'ai vu que j'avais sous lui avait
souhaité bon un bon étalon c'est quand
même et quand même bien la moindre des
choses est mal vécu cet homme est tombé
malade
c'est effectivement ça ça pousse à
l'attendrissement plutôt qu'autre chose
ça peut s'attendre ici même vous savez
un homme faible commence à être un homme
qui commence à attendrir alors que c'est
vraiment pas dans sa caractéristique
donc je pense que ça peut lui valoir des
voix supplémentaires éventuellement si
on avait à parler de ça alors on va on
va pouvoir en parler mais par contre
isabelle je voulais vous faire réagir à
ce que disait cet internaute qui
ironisait du figaro pendant des mois
donald trump à jo barre des 100 masques
sans être contaminés et puis après avoir
cédé à l'énorme pression entre
guillemets des progressistes il a enfin
mis un masque et hop il a chopé le virus
non on voit bien qu'il n'était pas
masqué d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous ont
sorti tous les éditorialistes américains
en expliquant que quand pour
l'intronisation de la nouvelle juge
personnes étaient masqués dans la petite
surprise party que effectivement au
moment du débat avec byden personne
n'était masqué de son de son côté à lui
et on faisait même un argument politique
qu'est ce qu'on voit que c'est devenu un
argument politique aux etats unis
les anti masques sont très très
profondément plutôt républicain il pense
qu'il ya un et qu'il faut que c'est un
acte de soumission que de mettre le
masque
non je pense pas par contre que je
trouve très habile vraiment de ça part
et ça il faut quand même souligner
l'habilité de cet homme si vous avez
remarqué il a fait une première
intervention ce matin en disant qu' il
avait beaucoup appris sur le covin le
grasse
il avait beaucoup appris donc il dit pas
je me suis trompé il dit j'ai beaucoup
appris et là il fait une déclaration ou
carrément effectivement maintenant il
est au plus près de ceux qui souffrent
ils luttent contre le vide et il incarne
en lui même la lutte contre le colis
dont au fond il ya un retournement de
situation total et il est prêt à
incarner captain america la lutte contre
quevilly donc c'est extraordinaire c'est
comme la force aussi de tous les
populistes c'est vrai c'est de sentir
les mouvements de l'opinion et on peut
lui reconnaître au moins ce talent ça
c'est sur votre pronostic vous pensez
que c'est lui portera ou non préjudice à
priori oui pour les raisons qui viennent
de t'expliquer je pense que ça
l'humanise en effet d'avoir cela portera
pas préjudice
je ne crois pas d'abord c'est même un
événement qui est à replacer dans sa
perdants dans ce qu'il est un événement
sanitaire ce n'est pas un événement
politique alors il prend une envergure
politique parce que c'est vrai qu'ils
l'avaient balayée quand même cette
menace jusqu'à l'or mais quand cette
menace vient le rattraper celle
l'humanise l'avantagé je pense que en
effet pour les raisons que vous avez dit
il là il a su assez bien retourner la
situation et faire en sorte de se rendre
encore une fois
qu'on ait envie en tout cas de compatir
ascenseur je ne sais pas si pas se
rendre vulnérable pour autant mais en
tout cas compatissant pour ceux qui le
regardent
et donc oui cela peut cela peut l'aider
j'ai eu imagine d'en faire en même temps
je pense qu'il est davantage portée par
un courant qui est le courant que vous
vous semblez défendre dans votre livre
c'est à dire le courant de 2 c de ces
peuples qui ne veulent pas disparaître
de ces peuples qui veulent s'accrocher à
leur souveraineté à leur identité alors
protection et 30 malgré tout va bien au
delà de tous les défauts qu'on peut bien
lui reconnaître tous les deux j'imagine
je pense qu'il invente une nouvelle
façon de faire de la politique
d'ailleurs il le dit lui même je
n'invente la politique du xxième siècle
et moi je me dévoue toujours pour être
l'avocat de trump en dépit de la thur
elle ment de tout c'est tous ces défauts
afin de bien faire comprendre qu'il l'a
qu'il a mis le doigt me semble-t-il sur
le ce qu'ils feront les élections de
demain c'est-à-dire une lutte entre les
mondialistes et les souverainistes ou le
mondialistes et les patriotes appelez
cela comme vous voulez et que ce sont
les slogans ont des souverainistes qui
aujourd'hui est portée par l'histoire
on y reviendra peut-être dans une
deuxième partie il ya peut-être une
autre question qui est soulevée par
notre confrère et autres contributeurs
de points de vie brice couturier qui dit
dans un tweet les médecins qui soignent
donald trump ne semble pas accorder le
moindre intérêt à l'hydroxyde l'euro qui
nous a volé en éclats de la cedh en
temps avis à ceux qui s'y accrochent
ouais vous dites c'est vrai
effectivement quand on regarde le
traitement de cheval elle dit le
brésilien parce que c'est vrai qu'avant
américain et cork corticoïdes un aux
lorraines désir c'était le médicament
qui a été promue par gilead et qui avait
fait des sauts en bourse rappelez-vous
donc qu'il a pris a priori à un acte
patriotique en prenant de raismes des
civils mais il avait précédemment fait
comprendre qu'il avait pris 2,86
chloroquine vous savez un moment où il
avait livré du liquide emploie des trois
pilules par jour pour savait vraiment
c'est le pas pour seul shirt venir mais
il aurait dû continuer qu'ils au même
nom mais là si vous voulez moi là la
question sur sur les médicaments sur les
traitements tout ça je sais pas si j'ai
vraiment envie de repartir là dedans par
contre c'est vrai que vous pouvez
répondre amodiations sur belle si on lit
donc les roues chloroquine oui là on a
vu qu'il avait choisi effectivement le
médicament américain maintenant on voit
bien que sur les mois je ne sais pas si
c'est le traitement anti à mettre en
scène ou plutôt je vous dis cet acte
s'est attelée pardon joucou ce qui
frappe en se frappant c'est quand même
que
on donne vraiment son traitement en ce
moment qui est en train de prendre
on se demande si ce n'est pas une pub
pour les traitements qu'il est on se le
demande pas là dessus rien ivan rioufol
a parfaitement raison c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il ya entre guillemets
le traitement français que les pêcheurs
qui étaient l'hydrochlorothiazide qui
pose qui porte à controverse et ailleurs
et il aurait même délire qui est le
traitement américain beaucoup plus cher
fait par des labos américain de toute
façon là effectivement vous avez raison
ivan rioufol lui de toute façon son truc
c'est à dire consommer américain fait
américain mary cas force est d'ailleurs
au fond on peut pas le lui reprocher ça
là dessus vous avez raison moi je pense
qu'on serait capable de faire un peu de
préférence européenne
chez nous on serait pas plus mal on
aurait été capable de préserver une
industrie médicamenteuse en europe on
serait beaucoup beaucoup mieux sur ce
les américains n'ont pas réussi à la
préserver non plus 93% des antibiotiques
consommée aux états unis viennent de
chine dont vous voyez c'est pas si
simple
65% des américains pensent que trump
n'aurait pas contracté le virus s'il
avait pris la menace au sérieux c'est en
tout cas ce que dit un dernier sondage
d'ipsos pour router et vous qu'en pensez
vous est-ce que vous pensez que donald
trump a été trop présomptueux vis-à-vis
du coville 19 c'est la question qu'on
pose sur twitter vous n'êtes pas
nombreux à avoir voté pour l'instant
vous répondez massive majoritairement
oui mais on va continuer à vous laisser
voter le temps que l'on fasse monter la
jauge aussi puisque là encore on peut
faire monter la jauge s'il inverse des
restaurants parisiens
maintenant on nous dit j'en ai assez
contraintes contracte trump de populiste
d'un autre côté pour trame c'est pas une
insulte mais moi je me considère
également comme étant populiste je veux
bien rattrapé cette insulte pour en
faire au contraire une sorte d'étendard
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut ce coup
ci le si on entend par populisme être le
porte-voix de ceux qui ne veulent pas
disparaître je pense qu'il est urgent
d'être populaire je ne sais pas si vous
serez d'accord avec cette analyse là
mais il me semble aujourd'hui que les
peuples sont dans une telle incertitude
civilisationnel existentielle sociale
identitaire et c'est qu'il y ait un
besoin de protection qui se décline à
tous points de vue
et encore une fois au risque de me
répéter je pense que que trump a fait
cette bonne analyse de dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'histoire est porteuse
protection et qu'en tout cas et qu'en
tout cas à travers les excès du
mondialisme et à travers les
conséquences du coc vide 19 qui oblige à
se protéger des frontières et à se
protéger tout court on voit bien que
qu'il avoue qu'il a eu à me semble-t-il
cette intuition au départ de dire que
ceux qui défendent est le mondialisme au
détriment de ceux qui défendent est le
patriotisme se tromper mais je pense que
cette histoire là le problème
il en fait une politique pour moi pas
tellement le problème c'est plus il est
le symptôme effectivement vous avez
raison c'est à dire qu'on a eu des
élites techno à la tête certainement
très bien fait hyper mondialiste qui est
jusqu'à présent n'ont absolument pas vu
la détresse dans laquelle est plongé les
peuples que ce sont les plus avancés le
peuple américain je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous ça c'est vraiment une
analyse que nous partageons par contre
je ne partage pas la solution c'est à
dire que je ne vois pas en quoi mettre
un trump un boris johnson ailleurs
bolton arrow va répondre aux besoins de
ces peuples qui ont effectivement une
envie de grandeur de se projeter vers
l'avant d'avoir quelqu'un qui a une
vision à long terme on voit bien que
regardez regardez ce qui nous fait avec
le coronavirus échanges d'avis 15 fois
il se met en scène on a l'impression si
vous voulez d'avoir une très très bonne
actes non je dis pas que ce soit le seul
mais on a l'impression d'avoir un acteur
un showman incroyable écouté il y aurait
eu un house of cards qui nous parlerait
de cette série américaine qui nous
parlerait du donald trump tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui on dirait qu'ils exagèrent
ils en font trop
on voit bien qu'on est là dedans
aujourd'hui or c'est parce qu'on demande
le mois geodis et je discerne une
contradiction dans ce que vous dites
parce que au nom j'ai bien compris que
vous étiez en attend des victimes en un
personnage qui représenteraient les
attentes du peuple
mais précisément le peuple le peuple
semble se reconnaître dans ce discours
le dans ce discours là c'est un discours
qui est un peu caricatural on est
d'accord avec ça je le personnage est
naturellement très très grotesque d'un
certain point de vue mais je crois
qu'ils appliquent précisément ce que
vous semblez attendre en tout cas je
sais mais c'est compliqué pour vous de
vous dire de vous dire 30 pistes ou
populistes je ne sais quoi ça ne l'est
pas pour moi j'ai envie que la populiste
je l'assumé totalement entre une piste
je ne suis pas américain mais je voterai
trump si j'avais à le faire si j'étais
américain en effet pour ces raisons là
en dépit encore une fois de la
personnalité de cet homme qui
naturellement est extravagant et qui ne
correspond pas du tout à fait à mes
critères si je puis dire de bienséance
mais
faudrait qu'ils aient recense est
populiste en fait le vrai problème il
est là il ya une vraie pour moi une
vraie différence là dedans c'est à dire
qu'au fond là on sent qu'il sorte sur
les vagues sur les angoisses sur les
attentes sur les les angoisses presque
complotistes pourquoi d'ailleurs elles
existent ces angoisses complotistes
parce qu'on voit bien qu'aucun politique
n'a été capable de répondre de façon
ferme à cette crise due qu'au guide et
voyez les errements dont on dansait
parle en france ils sont ils sont
identiques c'est pour reprendre la
question là je vous posais tout à
l'heure c'est celle de nathan qui dit on
il est ce qu emmanuel macron agnès buzyn
olive et veyran ont été meilleures que
trump
non mais c'est là là vous avez
parfaitement raison et d'ailleurs c'est
aussi pour vous attend au 15 mai non
mais mais nathan a parfaitement et c'est
une catastrophe on va pas dire le
contraire et il n'y a pas que le passé
et regardons aussi ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui quand on a vu la semaine
dernière cette descente devait rang à
marseille pour tous fermés sans même
prévenir le lamer de marseille et l'as
une conférence de presse pour ne rien
annoncer pour que hier à 22h30 à 22h30
nous apprenions par communiqué de presse
que les restaurants seraient en jauge
réduite que les bars à lait ferme et à
auxerre il ya un moment je trouve que
nos restaurateurs un son vraiment de
bonne composition
parce que pardonnez moi cette incise
mais apprendre la veille ou
l'avant-veille que vous allez faire mais
vous n'allez pas faire mais comment
font-ils leurs commandes
comment se propulse eut-il dans l'avenir
y'a un moment je crois que ces hommes
politiques qui plane complètement à
pardonnez moi cette trivialité me plane
quand qu'on arrive là haut degré zéro de
la politique dans cette manière qui est
faite du gouvernement d'instrumentaliser
effectivement des besoins de protection
mais en laissant tomber toutes les
protections les de l'assm ne serait-ce
que de la sécurité pour essayer de
mettre en mouvement une sorte d' état
sanitaire d'ordre sanitaire un peu
d'ailleurs technocratique et autoritaire
qui ne correspond pas à pas qui est fait
pour feindre naturellement une présence
de l'état fort mais qui me kiffe quilès
qui occulte dans le fond tout les tout
ce que l'état ne fait pas par ailleurs
je vois qu'on a abandonné le sujet tram
puisqu'on est arrivé un état de
consensus ce qui n'est pas le cas quand
on parle de tram d'habitude alors je
reviens donc au sujet bobby qui nous dit
c'est pathétique de devoir rattraper le
coup vide pour enfin accepter ce que lui
disent les scientifiques
populisme populiste est une nouvelle
insulte non justement au lit aulas
importe tous les cas c'est pas la
réponse
la réponse ils vont vous a répondu que
non et
et donc on a également chardons bleus
qui nous dit il doit faire la pub pour
leur md y virent effectivement c'est ce
qu'on a dit on
en tout cas ce qu on a déduit et
datant nous dit soit il prend de lâcher
q est ce n'est qu'un complotistes police
soit il prend le lead roxy chloroquine
pardon soit il filme on apprend tous les
jours et soit il prend leur md et vire
et c'est un nationaliste donc
apparemment trump a toujours tort nous
reproche de penser
nathan on vous posait la question pensez
vous que donald trump a été trop
présomptueux avec le co vite 10,9 et
vous répondez oui même là c'est un petit
peu plus fort à 65% et tout à l'heure
c'était à 60 2 %
l'autre question ce soir c'est
approuvez-vous les dernières
déclarations du pape françois sur les
migrants et les pays d'accueil parmi
elles celles relevées par notre confrère
jean-marie guénois qui s'occupent un les
questions religieuses au figaro vous
pouvez retrouver son art cliquant
vainement des aromates 12 mètres dans le
chat à la fois sur youtube et sur le
site du figaro parmi ces déclarations on
peut lire notamment les migrants si on
les aide à s'intégrer sont une
bénédiction
une richesse un don qui invite une
société à grandir chaque pays et celui
de l'étranger les limites et les
frontières des états ne peuvent pas
s'opposer à l'arrivée d'un migrant
yvan est ce que vous lirez la prochaine
encyclique du pape françois je la dirai
très certainement parce qu'il est
toujours intéressant de se faire
bousculer dans des certitudes dans des
conforts et terrain et je reconnais à ce
pape la dalle est à rebrousse poil en
tout cas des attentes majoritaire des
peuples qui on l'a dit tout à l'heure
sont plutôt en besoin de protection
qu'autre chose et ferment plus tôt les
frontières que qu'il n'a qu'il n'y ait
envie de les ouvrir
d'un autre côté moi je suis respectueux
du pape en règle générale et donc je
j'applaudis quand il nous dit qu'il faut
plutôt évité d'être du côté du manche
est plutôt être du côté des plus faibles
et donc tout ceci se fait partie du
discours évangélique que je trouve
parfait que l'on doit s'appliquer à tous
si on est un bon chrétien et je me
l'appliqué
j'essaie de me l'appliqué mais en même
temps il veut bassecourt évangélique
aujourd'hui c'est l'évangile du bon
samaritain et donc c'est une validation
surélevant sa meilleure à doha vendredi
noir est pas tomber dans l'angélisme
secours quelqu'un qui a été agressé au
bord d'un chemin après qu'un prêtre est
allé vite et refusait de se nourrir et
il ne faudrait pas tomber dans
l'angélisme alors que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans un monde qui devient un
monde de plus en plus conflictuel alors
je sais bien que naturellement si ce
serait j'applaudirais dès demain à 6
cette posture était une posture
exemplaire pour tous mais vous avez
quand même des civilisations qui voit
cette posture comme étant un acte de
faiblesse et donc je me dis qu'il y à un
manque de réalisme de ce pape qui
naturellement se regarde dedans danser
dans sa grande bon
etc je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit que
ce soit pris comme étant un incitatif
pour un certain nombre de cultures et
singulièrement pour la culture de
l'islam radical dont on voit bien
qu'elle a déclaré la guerre à ce que
nous sommes
à travers les chrétiens d'orient
notamment il suffit de voir quelle est
la position des chrétiens d'orient en
terre d'islam
pour voir qu'il ya les chrétiens
d'orient ne sont pas dans cette danse
est dans cette montée dame là et donc je
mets en garde en effet contre cette
posture faussement humaniste qui devient
une posture politique de la part de ce
pape c'est là où je le lui fait un
reproche c'est que il quitte au prétexte
en effet d'appliquer la parabole du bon
samaritain il quitte les sphères de la
religion pour s'impliquer dans un
domaine politique et en plus il le fait
en culpabilisant parce qu'il a eu des
mots très durs contre ceux des peuples
occidentaux
kipré qui craignent à raison une
ouverture à l'immigration ou en tout cas
qui voit bien que l'immigration n'est
pas simplement quelque chose de
bénéfique
voilà notre pape rhabiller pour un
projet du genre non mais qu'est ce que
est ce que je vous pose la question un
peu provoc en lisant votre votive vous
vous tirer à boulet rouge sur les sur
les élites déconnectées est-ce que c'est
pas des propos un peu parfois
déconnectés par rapport à ceux qui
éprouvent certaines parties de la
dépopulation alors qu'il a eu une phrase
quand même dans la le pape qui m'a fait
plutôt rigoler c'est quand il a dit
qu'il était contre l'efficacité
technocrates si les technocrates et est
efficace ça se saurait mais bon bref
non moi je pense que d'abord le pape est
dans son rôle de pape enfin situe là
vous l'avez rappelé très bien donc il
est dans son rôle de pape qui est quand
même dans un rôle voilà de charité et ça
me paraît la base moi je trouve que ce
qui est très intéressant là dedans c'est
toujours la même la même la même
dichotomie c'est à dire qu'on a d'un
côté l'angoissent l'angoissent
civilisationnel langoat viscéral de
toute une partie de la population qu'on
n'a pas à mésestimer qu'on peut tout à
fait comprendre et on a de l'autre côté
là comment dire l'échec total de toutes
les politiques d'immigration qui ont été
des politiques au fond de fermeture des
frontières qui n'ont pas fonctionné il
faut quand même il faut quand même le
reconnaître
d'ailleurs l'europe a reconnu d'ailleurs
elle-même qu'il fallait revoir cette
question d'oubli nages
il fallait revoir notre notre notre
rapport à l'immigration et on voit bien
qu'en fermant les contres les frontières
la seule chose à laquelle nous soyons
parvenus nous europe 1 c'est de nous
mettre dans les mains de la turquie à
qui nous avons délégué finalement notre
politique de l'immigration puisque nous
sommes pas capables nous continent 500
millions de personnes y faire face et 2
nous avons réussi enfin nous avons
réussi nous avons hélas réussi à faire
d'eux des passeurs 1 la troisième mafia
la plus lucrative
après larmes les armes et la drogue donc
la question qu'on doit se poser
aujourd'hui et c'est au fond ça c'est
comment on fait pour avoir une politique
qui fonctionne puisque ce qu'on met là
en place ne fonctionne pas on a des
milliers de morts dans la méditerranée
et ça on ne peut pas s'en satisfaire non
plus donc comment on arrive à mettre en
place une politique qui fonctionne
puisque de fait la fermeture des
frontières ne fonctionne pas non d'abord
c'était quand vous dites que la
fermeture des fonctions ne fonctionne
pas c'est à discuter parce qu'elle ne
fonctionne pas parce que les frontières
ne sont pas fermées c'est précisément
pour ça c'est que les frontières sont
poreuses et ensuite vous le promets je
pense qu'il faut replacer ce contexte
dans celui plus général de ce qui est
aujourd'hui le choc des cultures le
choc des civilisations en voit bien
aujourd'hui malgré tout pardon de le
répéter même si cela doit choquer qu'il
y a deux civilisations maintenant qu'ils
se confrontent et qui seraient qui
commence à se faire la guerre qui est la
civilisation occidentale d'un côté et la
civilisation islamique de l'ofc et
d'ailleurs c'est récurrent cela fait
maintenant des siècles et des siècles
que cela dure et donc on ne peut pas par
angélisme me dire il faut absolument à
baisser les frontières d'autant que si
le pape faisait un petit mot logis des
mots il se souviendrait que le paradis
dans son dans son acception d'humour qui
vient d'un vieux du vieux de la vieille
pers
cela veut dire un jardin clos de murs le
paradis s'est clos de murs et donc je ne
veux pas dire qu'il faut naturellement
fermer les frontières d'une manière
étanche mais je voudrais dire qu'à tout
le moins il faudrait entendre ceux qui
disent qu'ils il est difficile de vivre
ensemble avec des gens qui ne veulent
pas vivre avec vous ou en tout cas qui
ne veulent pas de synthèse regarder le
mur 30 pien n'a pas fonctionné non plus
on voit bien que tout ce qui est d'une
volonté de fermeture hermétique ne
fonctionne pas pour la bonne et simple
raison que quand vous avez vous quittez
votre pays que vous êtes prêt à vous
mettre en danger comme vous êtes prêt à
vous mettre en danger au fond plus rien
ne vous arrête donc c'est ça aussi le
problème moi la question si vous voulez
c'est que ça ne fonctionne pas donc
comment on arrive à penser une politique
ensemble une politique d'intégration
ensemble par ailleurs je pense que là
dessus on sera d'accord
vous avez vu notre président de la
république qui a eu un discours
politique fort sur ces questions là à la
fois un discours il répondait et à
l'ailé gauche et à la droite à l'ailé
gauche 11 cents soit moulures oui sur le
séparatisme en disant on est dans un
léviathan boiteux en france à partir du
moment où on offre pas d'intégration ça
ne fonctionne pas et il a raison et qui
a la foi disait au fond revenons sur
cette histoire d'intégration ce que
c'est vraiment ce que dit le pape sy
si on les aide à s'intégrer je répète un
fouet et citations sont une bénédiction
une richesse un don qui invite une
société à grandes idées reçues on
embellit la raison aussi un immigré qui
s'intègrent est une richesse vous avez
plein d'immigrés d'origine européenne
des italiens des polonais des espagnols
qui sont devenus plus français que moi
qui suis un vieux français et donc il
est naturellement ce sont des richesses
mais nous voit où on voit bien
aujourd'hui que le processus
d'intégration et d'assimilation a été
abandonnée a volontairement abandonnés
aux prêts au prétexte de ne pas
stigmatiser ou au prétexte de respecter
les différences et qui vient une
communautarisation enag un éclatement de
la société qu'a constaté le président de
la république en effet je me félicite
d'une partie de son discours mais vous
observerez comme moi qu'il n'a pas été à
la source précisément de celle survenue
de l'islam radical qui est quand même
une survenue qui est due également à
l'immigration si vous voulez stopper
l'immigration islamique il faut stopper
également cette immigration qui s'est
stoppée par dont la poussée islamique en
france il faut stopper cette immigration
qui il a qui l'a poussé à me paraît
logique mais la logique maintenant dans
les discours politiques et parfois
difficile à tenir
on va vous allez répondre joueurs
remettre un euro si je veux dire dans la
classe et en citant également encore une
fois le pape qui effectivement reprend
la position constante des papes sur
cette question de l'immigration quand il
y l'idéal serait d'éviter les migrations
inutile et pour y arriver il faudrait
créer dans les pays d'origine la
possibilité effective de vivre et de
grandir dans la dignité
ça rappelle un chef d'état africain je
pense de mémoire qui était alpha condé
qui disait que toute cette jeunesse qui
partait de ces pays là c'était une honte
pour ces gouvernements
alors ça si vous les skis et ski est
entre guillemets l'échec de ce
gouvernement c'est vrai c'est pas vrai
c'est à dire que quand on regarde le
profil des personnes qui migrent ce sont
plutôt les petites classes moyennes donc
si vous voulez dire au fond il faudrait
que ces pays se développe parce que ceux
développant elle ne quitterait pas leur
pays c'est pas très vrai c'est pas très
vrai statistiquement on sait aujourd'hui
que quand on vous savez qu'en regard
disait c'est toute la misère du monde
c'est parce que c'est parce que je vous
dise que je mens et peut-être certaines
certains cerveaux qui s'en vont c'est
peut-être pour ça mais je vous dis pas
que ce soit pas un problème pour ces
pays là je vous dis juste que la réponse
de gauche
en fait c'est pas compliqué tout le
monde a la même
volonté enfin tout le monde moi c'est
pour ça je n'y crois pas la politique de
gauche pour éviter l'immigration c'est
dire faisons une aide au développement
dans les pays d'origine
nous laisserons tous ses talents sur
place et nous les en empêcheront de
paille partir et la politique de droite
c'est fermant les frontières en gros si
je caricature mais la politique de
gauche ne fonctionne pas senti quelqu'un
sous sarkozy qui a eu à le ministère de
l'immigration et du codéveloppement avec
toute une politique de co-développement
avec brice hortefeux mais si vous sinon
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que ce
que je veux vous dire c'est que ça ne
fonctionne pas parce que quand bien même
ces pays se développe
thil et quand il se développe ses
classes moyennes ont envie d'aller dans
un la vie est plus douce et malgré tout
elle est beaucoup plus douce en europe
que là bas donc que en afrique que voilà
donc si vous voulez on a on a là dessus
à un mensonge qu'on peut aider les pays
en développement pour autant on
n'évitera pas la fuite des cerveaux
donc moi je pense qu'il faut réfléchir
plus en avant sur ses problèmes
d'immigration que de toute façon c'est
vrai qu'on ne peut pas arrêter une mer
qui monte avec les mains et donc cette
immigration s'imposera quoi qu'il arrive
mais il faut quand même maintenant
s'interroger de savoir si l'accès à la
nationalité doit être offert à ce point
d'une manière quasi automatique avec
leurs droits avec le droit du sol si le
droit du sol offre la nationalité à ceux
mêmes qui mena demande pas et cette
nationalité aujourd'hui elle est vue
parfois même comme une violence
identitaire parce qu'ils ne se sentent
pas français
et vous avez maintenant une partie de la
population musulmane ya eu un sondage de
l'ifop qui l'a dit encore très récemment
40 % des musulmans se disent d'abord
musulmans avant d'être français 75% des
jeunes musulmans moins de 25 ans donc je
termine mon raisonnement est donc je
pense qu'il faudrait s'interroger de
savoir aujourd'hui s'il ne faudrait pas
à revenir plutôt adroit de la volonté le
youth boutaty ce qui avait été un temps
d'ailleurs celui qui avait été retenu
par le par les révolutionnaires de 89,6
l'air de vous êtes est français celui
qui désire ardemment être français et
qui fait qu'ils s'assument jetty dans le
fond à nos règles
or si avec ce droit du sol des timbres
diplomatique à quel moment
bien déterminés à vos le fait part de la
détermination quand vous êtes majeur a
priori ou en tout cas ça me paraîtrait
ça me paraîtrait logique et je pense que
ce serait déjà davantage respecter
d'abord tout le monde y compris le pays
hôte enfin le pays et le pays d'accueil
et également ceux acquis noms qui n'ont
peut-être pas envie
quoi qu'il arrive de de partager une
identité qui n'est pas la leur parce
qu'ils n'ont pas cette culture ils n'ont
pas cette civilisation desriaux je donne
la parole aux internautes comme ça je
vous la donnera après il appelle vous
réagirez
je donne d'abord nathan qui lui dit la
charité ne consiste pas à donner sa
maison à un pot voici la conséquence est
de coucher dehors à sa place et qui nous
dit le pape doit rendre à césar ce qui
est à césar donc il doit se taire en
matière politique
oui mais oui là dessus je suis là dessus
je suis d'accord je trouve mais je
voulais dit tout à l'heure que le pas
quand jean paul ii était anti communiste
vous pensiez qu'il fallait que le pape
se taisent en terre je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il le disait ainsi il ne disait pas
je suis anticommuniste et en tout cas il
ne s'appliquait pas dans la diplomatie
tandis que l'un il s'implique quand même
dans un débat qui en plus le débat qui
est mien entier ils ont toujours fait
non pas parce font l'impasse coin pas à
ce point de culpabiliser parce que en
fait là il tient un discours de dire
qu'il faut à tenir un discours
mondialiste il faut s'ouvrir
obligatoirement à l'autre et ceux qui
s'opposent à ceux ci sont des xénophobes
il emploie le terme de xénophobes s'est
parfaitement désagréable moi je m'oppose
à ce si je tombe je veux bien qu'on me
dise de moi que je suis anglophone puis
un populiste et puis un facho et tout ça
pour quoi
ça fait quand même beaucoup à la fin
pour quelqu'un qui veut simplement
préserver une en tout cas à s'intéresser
à l'inquiétude de skill de ce qu'ils
croient être majoritaire le vrai
problème moi je trouve c'est que comment
se fait-il que l'allemagne arrive à
intégrer les immigrés que nous n'y
arrivions pas comment l'allemagne arrive
à se fournir finalement suffisamment de
cours d'allemand et center et que nous
n'y arrivions pas comment se fait-il que
nous soyons dans cette relation aussi
pathologique à l'immigration en france
moi c'est ça que je trouve dramatique la
mine est d'abord de savoir si
l'allemagne arrive vraiment à les
intégrer cette semaine will i am
erythrée la soie qui partait sur un
postulat de départ que je ne connais pas
mais le sanctionner à 5 15% d'adhésion
sur sur sa politique merkel alors même
qu'elle a fait cette grande ouverture
and migration et que tout le monde avait
dit que ça lui le besoin cash à
l'alimentation de la r d
oui enfin regarder l'augmentation de
l'afd par rapport à ce que représente le
front national en france
le rassemblement national sait rien
malgré tout je vous dis pas que ce soit
pas quelque chose mais enfin nous c'est
premier parti de france et le
rassemblement national et pourtant on
est censé avoir une politique de
l'immigration beaucoup plus strictes que
l'allemagne
donc il ya un vrai problème et ce
problème il est effectivement le
problème de l'intégration et là où je
vous rejoint ivan rioufol c'est que au
fond nous ne la faisons plus cette
intégration
donc nous la faisons plus nous laissons
pourrir la situation et là effectivement
c'est la question c'est pourquoi on l'a
fait plus et veste sur youtube ne dit
des migrants à céret en masse ne
s'intègrent jamais le multiculturalisme
est une utopie
est ce que justement il n'y a pas un
autre obstacle pardon d'être aussi
niveau talent mais à l'intégration qui
est aujourd'hui le nombre de volumes
non mais moi je pense pas parce qu'on
voit bien que quand on a là les chiffres
annuels
on n'est pas aujourd'hui dans une
explosion de l'immigration donc ça ça
n'est pas vrai non il ya eu il ya eu un
appel en 2015 aujourd'hui ça n'est plus
longue mais pas dire cela il ya quatre
cent mille personnes qui arrivent
légalement chacun d entre l'ailé droit
au séjour les 4,7 millions aujourd'hui
les 67 millions là je veux dire 400
mille par an que tous les ans rendez
vous compte ou à la fin ça commence à
déstabiliser déstabilise des identités
sadi stabiliser culture sacrée des
ghettos et vous voyez bien d'ailleurs il
suffit de regarder ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui vous avez une france qui se
libanaise qui se balkanisé en tout cas
une france qui sait que le vrai problème
le vrai problème pour moi ce ne sont pas
tant les arrivées que là où vont les
parcs
si vous voulez c'est toujours trop libre
et narry banlieues les plus pauvres
qu'on continue à faire venir ces
derniers arrivants c'est à dire ceux qui
à peine relève t-il la tête et à peine
arrive-t-il à s'intégrer qu'on les
ensevelisse nouveaux élèves il a raison
c'est bien pour ça que je dis qu'il faut
arrêter maintenant avec cette
immigration
on va regarder sur twitter on va bientôt
arrêter surtout l'émission c'est
d'arriver à la fin mais vous vous posez
la question sur twitter approuvez-vous
les dernières déclarations du pape
françois sur les migrants et des pays
d'accueil et vous répondez non en
majorité à 75%
pragma nous dit la ré mi temps c'est de
l'argent des migrants vers leur pays
d'origine c'est plusieurs dizaines de
points de pib dans certains pays
effectivement c'est un autre sujet de
deux débats effectivement on y reviendra
peut-être on va sûrement dans des
prochains peut-être point de vue ou bien
également sur figaro live fratelli tutti
c'est la dernière encyclique du pape
françois elle est en vente aujourd'hui
je donne pas l'éditeur qui m a toujours
plein et donc c'est en librairie et
c'est également disponible sur internet
rendez nous la france c'est disponible
sur internet mais moyennant finances
mais ça vaut le coup donc je vous invite
vraiment à faire le pas rendez nous la
france donc c'est isabelle saporta
essais chez fayard et je vous invite
également à faire le pas pour un lire
acheter le dernier livre de ivan rioufol
rue yvan rioufol pardon je suis très
troublé très troublé les journalistes de
talent me troublent le réveil des
somnambules et chronique d'une colère
qui monte et c'est aux éditions de
l'artilleur on se retrouve demain ici
même heure même endroit on se donnera
également rendez vous dans un petit peu
plus d'une heure même deux heures à 19
heures 30 audition publique avec la
chaîne parlementaire et public sénat
avec comme invité
marlène schiappa je reprendrai une de
vos questions pour la poser à la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur
[Musique]